foreign
hey you guys what's going on uh it's
Sunday everybody knows that probably
yeah it's not day we're doing Top Gun
too
top gun Maverick top gun Maverick yeah
we finally finished what we finished
watching the last thing yeah because it
was free it was free well for everyone
if you have Amazon Prime you can watch
it on there yeah I do kind of wish we
had seen this in the theater like I'm
not gonna cry about it or anything like
that but
um because I kind of feel like we
watched half of it on Thursday night I
feel like and then uh we watched the
rest of it last night because it's kind
of long it's like two and a half hours
or whatever
and I will say I liked the second half a
lot better like once it got into all the
aerial [__] and like all the dog
fighting and like the actual Mission and
everything that was like badass I really
like that you know what I mean it's uh
it's a good flick yeah
um the quality is top-notch Tom Cruise
does does some really good acting in it
um it is nostalgic
yeah it is a nostalgic movie and they're
trying to bring back kind of like that
military action drama
kinda
segment they're you know you know that
that kind of movie they used to have
back in the 80s yeah that's basically
what they're doing that when you call it
a genre yeah it's kind of like that
genre
um I think it succeeded yeah big time uh
yeah this [__] was a [__]
Blowout at the box office and I can see
why it's traditional there's nothing
fancy about the storytelling in this
it's
yeah it's pretty straightforward yeah I
almost kind of want to say basic [__]
but that's the way this genre was yeah
so I think that that was the right call
not to get real artistic with this
um
real good flying action sequences uh and
then you know Maverick gets shot down I
think he gets shot down twice today uh
steals airplanes
so but it is a carryover from the
mission impossible yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's the thing um I don't know if you
know this but this was directed by
Joseph uh Kaczynski Kozinski and he was
the same guy that directed Oblivion okay
uh and he also did Tron legacy which I
haven't seen but I've everybody said
that that was really that's the second
one right yeah yeah it was pretty good
that was like the I didn't see it it was
pretty good yeah and it's got Jennifer
Connelly in it she's fine as [__] man
she's looking on man she still looks
great yeah she's my age I think yeah or
she might be a year older and I think
she's a year older than I am she was
always fine
yeah my whole life that girl was fine
yeah and she still is yeah she looks
fantastic in this I remember how
gorgeous she was in The Rocketeer yeah
she's probably in her 20s you know and
really her beauty hasn't faded she's
just she's who does not love Jennifer
Connelly she has got to be she is like
one of the most beautiful women on her
she's a cougar she's still and she still
is even though she's I think she's 51
because like I said I'm pretty sure
she's about my age she was great in an
elite a battle Angel too another one of
my favorite movies
the interesting thing while I was
watching because I haven't seen the
original Top Gun in a long time
because like I said I don't you know
it's it's fine it's a fine movie the
original one from 86 but it's like I
don't love it or anything like that
but um I was wondering because in Top
Gun Maverick there's like that you know
they have to have the Romantic side plot
because that's just what you did like an
80s Blockbusters and they're kind of
trying to Homage that a little bit while
also updating it but so she's like the
love interest and they're talking like
her and Tom Cruise's character Maverick
are talking like they had like this big
long history and I was just kind of like
well was she even referenced in the
first movie so I looked it up and she
was she wasn't actually in the first
movie obviously because in 1986 I think
Jennifer Connelly was only about 16
years old or no like I said she was
probably the same age as me so I was
14. so she was probably 15. so yeah that
wouldn't that would have been weird but
um but I her character Penny was
mentioned as I think that goose says
something like some offhand comment to
Maverick that
um oh that Admiral's daughter that you
got with or whatever so that's who so
they actually did like take just an
offhand comment from the first movie and
like made her an actual character so I
thought that was kind of cool that they
did that because I was like now are we
just pulling this out of our butts or
what because it's been a while since
I've seen the original but I like that
they kind of had that continuity with it
because I guess they didn't I mean Kelly
McGillis is still around but I guess
they didn't ask her to be in the movie
they didn't ask Meg Ryan to be in the
movie either did they say in this movie
that Goose's wife who Meg Ryan played in
the original that she had died I didn't
catch any of them because I was watching
like another like a video essay about
this and they said something about oh
they mentioned that she had died like in
the interim between the two movies and
I'm like I don't remember hearing that
but it's like it's possible I could have
missed it the movie's kind of typical of
the genre
where it's an enjoyable watch even if
you're not really paying close attention
you can just kind of cruise through it
because it's got a good soundtrack you
said cruise through it yeah
it's got a good something it's got a
good it's got a good soundtrack and a
good score and just fun [__] happens you
know and dudes fighting and dudes being
over the top competitive and [__]
which it's kind of [__] you know
what I mean but that's just that was the
that was the genre of this but that was
and that was the way the originals so
they were kind of trying to like keep at
the same tone and I think they were
largely successful yeah try to keep the
[__] Top Gun Pilots as dicks you know
that they were dicks basically you know
it's hilarious you know the guy that
plays like you know the douche canoe in
this yeah hangman I think is his name
and uh that when they gave him the
script he almost didn't want to do it
because he said you know oh I'm just
going to be there to be the quote
unquote dick garnish yeah yeah and I was
like oh my God I love them
Jenny loves Dick garnish
maybe just think of like a penis with
like a little piece of like [__] with
a little piece of what is that [__]
called just waiting for you to buy me
some dick guards
let me get you a little little what the
[__] is that [__] called that green [__]
that you put on like this like parsley
parsley thank you I can't I could not oh
my God I have mad cow seriously I can't
like think the [__] women would think
of that met a dick and parsley
well what that's the first thing I
thought of with dick garnish I thought
it was just like with a little piece of
parsley like sticky that's what I
thought of when he said that's some
crazy [__] tonight stop putting that man
on that tree in there
[Laughter]
um yeah I thought the movie was was good
yeah it's pretty entertaining like I can
see how like a mission impossible kind
of movie they got and there's a lot of
ripping off of [__] Star Wars in the
[__] oh my God
going down in the trench and dropping
the bomb right into the hole Yeah and
hey you know [__] uh he's turned off
his targeting computer and all that kind
of stuff yeah it's okay I got it I got
it don't worry about it yeah we were
making like Star Wars yeah yeah yeah
they and I know that joke I know that
[__] was on purpose but it was good you
know loosen up they're coming in behind
me thanks wedge
he got Porkins
they came from behind
but yeah so that's why I'm not [__]
on the baby I'm just saying it's like I
thought that was fine because like the
second they laid out the whole mission
that they have to do
I was just kind of like that's that's
Star Wars they're they're essentially
destroying this yeah the Death Star is
what they're doing there yeah and
[__]
Tom Cruise I'm just gonna call him Tom
Cruise because that's who he is he plays
himself in all of his movies pretty much
yeah he uh uh has to fight a a a [__]
anime Ace
they never just say what country this is
it's just kind of yeah they didn't want
to piss anybody off I guess it's some
kind of [__] Slavic country so it's
probably Russia or something like Russia
but uh at the the Jets look like migs
real high-tech migs and [__] but didn't
even didn't he shoot down some eggs in
the first movie so maybe that's why
they're yeah or is that a different
movie so many countries had migs the
Soviet Union sold those things to
everybody
even had some Allied countries like in
South America that had migs even though
they were friends of ours
so it didn't necessarily wasn't
necessarily enemy can I say like I
didn't know I had kind of heard like
some of the [__] about like how they
made this movie and everything like that
because this took a while to do I guess
they were even talking about doing a
sequel to Top Gun way the [__] back in
the 90s and Tom Cruise is like nah man
we don't need to do that but then like
they started talking about it even more
and they were gonna get Tony Scott back
to do it
um but you know he sadly uh committed
suicide in what 2012 I want to say so we
kind of got yeah he was the guy that
directed he's Ridley Scott's brother oh
yeah he was the guy that directed the
original one yeah and uh so yeah so they
wanted him on board but you know that
kind of put a kibosh on that whole
situation
so they brought in Joseph Kaczynski
after because like I said you know he
had worked with Tom Cruise on Oblivion
which is also a good movie if you
haven't seen it one of the better ones
that Tom Cruise has been in like I said
if you know if you've been around here
for a while you guys know um I'm not the
hugest fan of Tom Cruise I think he's
kind of like an arrogant douche and also
that whole Scientology thing really kind
of like I'm going to defend him well I
know you weren't a short man but
but I am gonna say
that as annoying as he probably is to
deal with in real life
um when he makes a movie he [__]
commits and he is gonna like [__]
make that the best possible movie he can
make it yeah and that that flies for
this movie like a hundred a thousand
percent because I was thinking the whole
time I was watching the the jet fighting
sequences like where they were flying in
the [__] [__] I was like that can't
be CGI that does not look like CGI and
indeed it is not they did actually put
those [__] actors yeah in fighter
jets yeah they're not flying them
obviously but they what they did was
they would have it so that the person
flying like the pilot was kind of in the
front and then they would put the other
ones in the back and then they would
have the controls for the camera so they
were essentially filming themselves yeah
in the J and they also had all the Jets
had cameras uh like four or five cameras
on the inside and then like a bunch on
the outside also so they could film the
[__] in flight so they actually did I
think the they paid like 11 thousand
dollars an hour or something like that
like to have these Pilots like do the
[__] now some of the dog fights and
stuff I think they did use CGI for that
because they didn't want I guess because
of liability and stuff they would film
like a single jet like doing all these
Maneuvers and then they would kind of
like composite it together but all of
those actors like when you see all their
faces smoosh and like the high you know
the g-force and all that kind of stuff
that is absolutely real and they did all
that [__] and I was just kind of like
that is [__] crazy
because when I was watching it like I
said I was like there's just no way that
that's CGI they must have really put
those people in the planes because
it didn't you could tell that it wasn't
fake you know what I mean and like so
when I looked again I was like oh
that's why it wasn't fake they were
actually like flag at this point which
is amazing had a realistic feel inside
the cockpit they're doing G pulling G4S
and negative G and [__] so they look
good Tom can fly though I don't know if
he could fly a fighter jet
although a fighter jet I believe
probably pretty easy to fly there's a
lot of software
helps them fly those
um but I don't think they just let you
fly their fighter jet well they're like
look we like you Tom Cruise but not that
much I think he's settled down I don't
even think he can fly helicopters
thing
if I remember correctly myth memory
serves and choppers are a lot harder to
fly than a
jet fighter
but jet fighter you better be ready for
[__] speed [__] are fast man
and in this movie they're flying them
fast low to the ground
yeah yeah
that's kind of part of the mission is
that they have to go would they say they
can only fly like a hundred feet off the
ground or some [__] like that it's 660
knots I think yeah and then they have to
go like and then they have to go through
this really complicated like I said it's
basically like the Death Star they have
to go through this really complicated
like Valley or whatever and then they
have to go up in this mountain and like
down in the mountain blow up the thing
and then go way up over the mountain
again like it's just so the the other
missiles they've got to go down the
Death Star trench yeah there's even flat
guns flat towers outside of the [__]
trench they got all that
yeah but see I mean they knew what they
were doing they leaned into it I mean
that's right they're destroying the
death stars what they're just I mean it
would have been I don't know if it would
have been funnier if not or if one of
the characters had said that like if
like he would have raised his hand like
in the training Mission and be like so
we're essentially like killing the Death
Star is what we're doing it's like yeah
pretty much that I don't know if that
would have been funny or if I would have
rolled my eyes when the first dude they
had to drop the bomb twice in in on the
target which is just like
the first few drops you drop a camera no
it didn't go
didn't go sir that's what he said
he said we were just making duster like
we were making dust our jokes like the
whole thing
[__] loving New Hope man they even
got the [__] you've got the throat
mic sound right you know so we're taking
a lot of fire from the [__] Towers
so this is yeah this is essentially Star
Wars but with
but this was actually I kind of feel
like this was a way better movie than it
really needed to be and I'm gonna go out
on a limb I don't even think this is out
on a limb but um I like this a lot
better than the original movie yeah I
was gonna I was gonna say um I think I
saw the original in the theater and was
indifferent and then it would shoot up a
lot on um like it was all right yeah it
was just yeah yeah it was better than
Days of Thunder well you know a lot of
movies yeah
that was another one you had to see when
it came out I didn't have to I saw I did
that reviews no I I think I did see it
yeah it was not on purpose summertime
[__] visiting my dad Mississippi and
[__] every week he had every weekend
you had to go and see some movies yeah
you know so I can gotta keep up with you
gotta keep up with [__] you know so
seeing the movies and
but uh now Top Gun came out some some of
my friends down there really [__]
loved it you know but I was like I
didn't really see what was all that
special about it you know it just kind
of captured yeah I don't know I was
watching something earlier and they said
mainstream is [__] it was yeah which
like I said even back in 1986 I wasn't
really about that right
um and like I said I'm not a big fan of
movies that just have like a bunch of
cocky [__] yeah uh as characters
because that mainly just makes me want
to punch their faces so
um and this has a little bit of that but
you have you know the dick garnish
character that's what we're gonna call
them hangman
um but he's really the only one the
other ones are mostly just pretty much
normal yeah they do kind of like [__]
with each other and stuff but they're
not as much of a jerk as he is like yes
I'm awesome yeah thank you for asking
you know what I mean and I'm just like
oh my God shut up but he I mean you know
he has like an arc too and he gets like
more normal he's probably like still a
douche at the end but he's like less of
a douche maybe like two percent less
yeah I don't know what Top Gun Pilots
are actually like
um I'm ex infantry from Airborne
infantry uh divisions and
my squad leaders and a lot of my friends
ended up going to [__] Ranger schools
and some of them bullled out some came
back with tabs and [__] our version of a
Top Gun infantry would be a rager Army
Ranger
uh yeah they were dicks uh but they
weren't that kind of Dick they were evil
yeah kind of crossed between it down
convict and something out of the SS
those are kind of look at what they were
like
evil little [__] we just call them
skull people because they'd come back
from [__] great people people yeah at
least he's coming back like a [__]
skull
because they come back out of Ranger
school so [__] emaciated because it
just it just strips so much muscle and
fat off of them because they starve them
you know and they come back cruel
um but experts at
being a dick you know and being mean
well see I always kind of feel like the
character of um hangman in this and to a
smaller extent like the characters in
the original movie too I've always found
in my experience that people that are
like real over the top cocky like that
usually can't do the [__] because
they're overcompensating yeah so it's
like it's kind of unusual to come across
somebody who can do all that cool badass
[__] and is still like that dudes who
made it through Ranger selection and
went to Ranger school left [__]
scared because they weren't scared of
the school they were scared of failure
yeah yeah because they come back and
you're like oh man you didn't make they
spent all that money to send you there
and you [__] blow it out you know
that kind of [__] [__] it up you never
really live it down so it's an all or
nothing you know back in back in the 90s
that's the way it was early 90s it was
all or nothing you either came back with
a [__] Ranger tab or you didn't
[__] come back
some of those guys recycled several
times no no no no let me go let me try
again
some of them just quit
came back as shame you know yeah oh yeah
Tara that's the [__] hardest School
harder than [__]
physically and mentally harder than
Special Forces Special Forces is hard
too it's longer more intellectual and
[__] Rangers just about how much damage
you could take you know can you walk
yourself to death
can you go without sleep for a long long
time and pull infantry patrols and [__]
it's just torture really it's a nut
check and they come back they don't know
anything other than what they knew
before they just
battle proven you know
learning their limits that you will that
those dudes will actually just kill
themselves basically that they'll kill
themselves to get the [__] done yeah
that's all they want to know
Camp guy said I didn't buy the Jennifer
Connelly character as a barkeep bar
owner at first but it grew on me through
the movie yeah I actually did really
like her I would argue that you know not
every movie has to have um you know a
romance subplot but the original one had
it and so they were kind of like getting
with and I can kind of see that they
were trying to show that Maverick was
had like matured
because they kind of make a lot of
um implications that he had that that
him and Penny Jennifer Connelly's
character had kind of like hooked up at
a bunch of points in the past and he
kept like [__] her over and so like
at the end you're led to believe that
he's finally got his [__] together and
he's gonna stay with her now and stuff
like that so I get that you know what I
mean it's very like you said it is a
very mainstream movie but that's
obviously what people like because this
was the second highest grossing movie of
2022. it made 1.5 billion dollars that's
billion with a B uh all over the world
and uh that's even after like I don't
even think it got released in China so
that's like not without them watching it
it still made one and a half billion
dollars do you know what and I was kind
of curious I was like well what was the
what was the number one one then it was
Avatar and I was like really okay I
didn't hear as many talk people talking
about the new Avatar movie as I did the
Top Gun movie but I guess Like Somebody
went to see that [__] because that made
even more than 1.5 billion dollars so I
was like okay fair enough but um
but I can see why like I said I kind of
feel like
this this struck a really good balance I
feel like between it had all the [__]
like you know all the fan service that
you would expect like if you're a fan of
the or of the first movie like it had
kind of like the camaraderie it had you
know a scene where they're all like on
the beach with their shirts off like
playing football or whatever the [__]
you know it was volleyball in the first
movie but you know they had another
scene like that so it had a lot of like
equivalent stuff like you know it had
the romance thing it had you know a
similar kind of plot beats but I feel
like it also I thought it went a little
bit deeper with the character work I'm
not gonna go too far in that direction
because it's not like some [__] deep
character examination or anything like
that but it had a lot more
emotional resonance I feel like than the
first one did and I think that that was
like Tom Cruise he actually kind of did
Lean Into His roles like I'm an older
guy now now I've become the instructor
and he has like a lot of regrets in his
life and [__] like that so his character
was like a lot more
you know he had a lot more depth or a
lot more like um interest to him I guess
than just kind of like this young hot
shot cocky [__] that was just
trying to be better than the other dude
it's a much better movie than the first
one it is I kind of feel like it is
which is crazy because it's like I feel
like they had been throwing the idea of
this around for so long for like decades
and then everybody now they're like dude
it's like 20 22. it's like too late that
movie's like so old and you know we're
getting the same guy and what the [__]
is that about but then like it comes out
and just like blows everyone's socks off
the thing is about the first Top Gun
movie I always put it in the same
category as [__] Roadhouse
you know what I mean remember that movie
[__] with yeah Patrick Roadhouse I
kind of love I kind of had that tone to
it it's so cheesy yeah I thought
something was kind of cheesy yeah it was
cheesy kind of about nothing really it
was cheesy not much happens in it that I
think you know I mean they had some dog
fights I don't even think anybody got
shot down maybe they did
I don't think they ever got yeah maybe
they did get some shoes I barely
remember
I'm Skirmish somewhere there wasn't much
plain action to it from what I remember
or nothing that really stuck with me
because they were just students then
right they were like you know it went to
Top Gun school and then something
happened later on they had to do
something I don't remember a guy got
killed during trading too
um
I just didn't think there was much to
that movie at the time I was like
there's not much to this one is
delivered they're trying to do Star Wars
yeah exactly I mean it's just like a
death star run crowd-pleasing yeah and I
will say that like toward the end and I
think this is a credit to you know the
filmmakers and the actors who were
actually willing to get their asses up
in a fighter jet and like because I
would absolutely not do that I'd be like
yeah no thank you I'm quitting but um
you get some other [__] to go up
there and do that [__] because I'm not
doing it but the fact that they got
everybody up there do that and like the
way that they shot it and everything
like that it really kind of like raised
the stakes so I kind of feel like the
whole third act where they're doing the
mission and then like you know obviously
they can't just do the mission and it's
successful but then they kind of get
seen by like the enemy planes and now
they gotta like dog fight and then it's
like some of them crash and all this
other kind of stuff so it was like it
was really you know you really got into
it because you're just like holy [__]
look at all this [__] [__] going on
and it was like really I don't know you
really kind of like on the edge of your
seat even though I didn't really I will
say that I like that Tom Cruise was
willing to kind of be more vulnerable
honorable I won't say that he was like a
like a side character because he's not
he's absolutely the main character but I
like that he was willing to kind of like
showcase like the other actors a little
bit as well even though I kind of feel
like a lot of them were a little thinly
drawn perhaps grandpar said that the
first one had homosexual Vibes oh this
one's got gay Vibes in too they homage
the [__] volleyball and and yeah
although it does it's not quite the same
as I mean it's not the first movie I
mean obviously like I watched it and I'm
like Tom Cruise and Val Kilmer I'm like
would you guys just kiss already Jesus
Christ in this one Tom Cruise is playing
volleyball and they homage the [__]
famous [__] [__] it I think it's
football actually but yeah they're on
the beach but they do this [__] kind
of the same thing where he's like I love
you man no homo pretty much yeah but it
was yeah it wasn't as over the top as
the first one but they know that you
know about that scene yeah and well
because that's what a lot of people talk
about people like erotic thing which
which like I said in the 80s I kind of
feel like people went over their [__]
heads
sometimes I I kind of feel like they
weren't really aware that that's what
they were doing it went over their heads
sometimes they were but I kind of feel
like they were and especially that my
[__] teenage buddies watched that
[__] [__] love that movie they didn't
notice it that's what I'm saying so I
kind of you guys did notice it in the
80s they didn't really they're just like
yeah yeah yeah man yeah that's badass
that's machuation like man those dudes
need to [__] that's it that's gay that's
the first time I saw it I was like I
just wanted like why don't they can't
say Korean clearly love each other well
yeah because that's the thing about the
original like the whole romance thing
with Kelly McGillis I didn't I remember
not really buying that
um because I kind of feel like the
chemistry was a lot you know was a lot
more uh pronounced like between him and
Val Kilmer's character between Iceman
now we have to say that Val Kilmer
he reprises his role as Iceman in this
movie he's only in one scene
um obviously you know Val Kilmer had uh
throat cancer and he's apparently beaten
it uh I guess but he can't really talk
that much anymore so they kind of used
that in the movie like because in the
movie his character who's he's like an
admiral right and he's kind of been like
over the 30 years between the two movies
he's kind of like gone to bat for
Maverick and like got him jobs and stuff
and kept him from getting court martials
or whatever for all the [__]
Shenanigans he pulls but I like that
they kind of leaned in because everybody
knows that Val Kilmer everybody knows
about his struggle with cancer and
everybody knows about that kind of stuff
so they actually kind of wrote that into
the movie where he has cancer in the
movie and he can't really talk and he's
dying and stuff like that and there's
like a really nice scene between uh
between Maverick and Iceman where he
goes to see him and he's like asking
about the [__] granters noticed
something about the movie that yeah
that's right did you notice Tom Cruise's
name wasn't in the opening credit is
that because he's too big at this point
to be lumped with the cast yeah uh you
know he's in this [__] movie yeah
he's like we don't need to tell people
obviously yeah I'm Tom Curry yeah
[__] I don't want my name on
there
well he was a producer
[__] Tom Cruise and I feel like well
like I said this took a long time to get
released because they were working on
this for a few years and then you know
there was pandemic and then they were
like well then it got pushed back more
because they wanted to like make the
active the flying sequences better like
they and they were really complicated
and Tom Cruise was pretty adamant about
making this like I said pretty much like
the perfect movie he wanted this to be
as good as possible and even though he
got like a bunch of offers to like from
streaming services like Paramount plus
and stuff like that and they're just
like hey we want to like show this
[__] movie but he wouldn't do it he's
like this has to be a theater movie so
he like pushed really hard for it being
theater only so they had to like push it
back like several years it was a hell of
a [__] gamble paid off though it was
it really did pay off and and the thing
about it is Tom Cruise I mean he gets uh
a portion of that's in his contract say
what you want about Tom you know what I
mean the Scientology and his count couch
jumping and [__] like that Tom [__]
delivers Tom Cruise he does I will give
him that yeah as like I said as and I
said this before I said as douchey as he
probably is in person
um when you go see a Tom Cruise movie he
never phones that [__] in yeah uh he
always learns to do the [__] you know in
the boutique right he really rides
motorcycles he really flies in jet
planes he really like hangs off the side
of mountains he really does all that
[__] so you know I have mad respect for
him for doing that like I said I don't
like him as a person I don't like that
Scientology [__] but
um but he will always give like a
crowd-pleasing movie and he never just
like phones that [__] in like he always
gives it 110 now to Witnesses in
Scientology that know him like
high-ranking Scientology people that
have defected he's not douchey he's [__]
he's described as diabolical that's what
he really is he's dive out which like I
said that does not surprise me at least
because that's how he's always come
across to me
he's always and I think that's why
that's what kind of like turned me off
him like from his early movies that's
why I didn't really get into his early
movies either like risky business or all
that kind of stuff because I'm like I
don't really like I don't like that
over-the-top cocky like I'm so confident
oh you love me blah blah oh my God I
hate that guy he's real evidently he's
real manipulative and kind of cruel and
[__] he treats uh other people in
Scientology who are lower ranker than
him it's like a paramilitary type
situation I understand what he's doing
but supposed to be a religion it's not
you're not in the [__] Army Rangers
or the Navy Seals you know everybody
[__] basically getting people to drop
and do push-ups and just the same kind
of mentality right it is yeah you know
you know [__] you go back to the
barracks or punishing people and [__]
you know he's diabolical I I grew up
with it being military and military
schools going back it's just normal and
it was never really most of the time it
was never really mean-spirited
but they say he's diabolical
like that does that doesn't surprise you
yeah especially knowing as much as I
know about scientology and having had to
deal with them like and my workplace
like a while back
um I know what they're like and I know
what the kind of people that that it
produces so I could totally see like how
how that would come out
uh he may not like scientologists
actually because he's friends with David
miscavige and Davis Miss cabbage the guy
who's the CEO or what they call the cob
the guy who runs Scientology hates
science yeah he hates [__]
scientologists he thinks they're [__]
idiots
and he treats them accordingly well
that's the only thing that he said that
we can agree on well no I'm just saying
I'm now as I said before I'm not like if
you were born into Scientology then man
get the [__] out of there one
um that's not your fault uh you don't
know any different but people that join
it later I'm just like I don't
understand why anybody would want to do
that that's especially now that we know
it's like you know it might have been
easier to fall for it back in the day
like when you didn't know if you've
gotten it before the internet and like
you got sucked into it and everything
but nowadays there's no excuse It's like
nobody needs to get into that kind of
[__] yeah it's a UFO cult essentially
that's gonna take all your money yeah
that teaches you tries to teach you
[__] psychic psychic abilities like a
force or something yeah we made a lot of
OT Powers while we were watching this
too like like I said it's a good movie
but it's like I because I'm such a big
fan because I've watched Mystery Science
Theater for so many years it's reflexive
I can't watch a movie even if I love the
movie I just keep making like snarky
comments about it I just I can't help it
I can't help it grafter said Kelly
McGillis has not aged well poor thing
that's what I heard I haven't seen her
recently
um you know because she hasn't been in
anything for a while I don't remember
that is she was in the original Top Gun
I don't remember she was the the blonde
that was like the that was the love the
main love interest she was like the
instructor yeah yeah yeah yeah okay so I
don't know what she looks like now but
yeah I've heard that she didn't like oh
yeah there's a lot of hotties that
[__] that are still around but you'll
never see them again because they look
terrible now there was somebody pointed
one out
to me and I was like man that's her you
know I can't remember who it was man we
I think we talked about it on the show
earlier it's another one of the blondes
it was worth a lot of money in the
movies she's totally unrecognizable
totally [__] now I don't remember who we
were talking about yeah I think we
talked about her before we were talking
about the only blonde I remember
mentioning to you in the last few days
was Bridget Nielsen no not her
uh Camp guy said we just watched this on
streaming I remember who it was who
Bridget Fonda Bridget Fonda oh right
totally unrecognizable that girl was a
knockout in like Nikita you see her now
she was in everything in the 90s I feel
like she was all over I had a hard time
wrapping my mind around that that was
the same woman
but it was her yikes that's right you
showed me yeah and I was like oh yeah
man
that sucks yeah because she was in yeah
she was in all kind of yeah we still
haven't reviewed single white female
have we no I don't think so now man I
love single white female that's such a
great [__] movie
uh that was her and uh Jennifer Jason
Lee
granther says the reason why people
liked it is because it was fun and
people want to have fun watching movie
yeah I kind of feel like that was this
was just like a purely it's not super
deep or nothing like that it was just
kind of like it was a a amazing like
visual spectacle and it had like enough
of depth to the story that you kind of
got into the characters you got
emotionally invested it was just a good
time it was just really like
entertaining you know what I mean just a
very simple
entertaining kind of movie which like
you said there's I kind of feel like
they made a lot of those back in the 80s
and maybe not so much anymore but I
don't know I kind of feel like they do
still make a lot of movies like that I
feel like a lot of the Marvel movies are
kind of like that or they're just kind
of like big dumb fun
says Tom Cruise is the Bruce Springsteen
of movies goes balls out for every
performance he does and like I said I do
respect him for that there's a lot of
things I don't like about him but and I
don't as a rule I don't usually kind of
like be like ooh new Tom Cruise movie is
out we should go see that because he's
usually in like these big like I said
like big Blockbuster type movies and I
tend to not like those with some
exceptions I like them because that's a
genre yeah and but you know what I'm
talking they're generic but they're
usually fun for me yeah sometimes I'm in
the mood for that yeah
I was big into Oblivion but the bit uh
uh the collateral was really good I did
I like to kill that earlier yeah those
were kind of like his uh uh
kind of called classic type movies in a
way they were they were not really they
were big movies but they they weren't
aimed at a mainstream kind of audience
[__] the mission impossible series
they're all good they're all movies of
the time of their times
that every I think I've seen them all
except maybe the very newest one I don't
know I think that another one came out
recently I I gotta go I remember we saw
Fallout will fall out in the theater
yeah and I liked that that was good I
don't remember and then fall out or
Fallout Rogue Nation or I don't remember
I think with Rogue Nation I saw that one
though every bit as good as a Daniel
Craig James Bond movie yeah
um
Tom [__] delivered and all that [__]
the first one was a John Woo movie it
had the kind of cheesy [__] 90s Kung
Fu right even that was for the for the
day it doesn't really hold up if you ask
me for the in the yeah I didn't think it
held up it didn't help but in the in its
day it was quite cool
um it was but
the whole series is is good real good
and the newer ones I think are fantastic
um
but uh now Tom doesn't really even even
his [__] flop The Mummy I liked it
I did not I liked it it's just a big gum
monster movie with a headphone it was
that for sure yeah it had all the
monsters in it it was kind of like lead
the League of Extraordinary Gentlemen
and [__] The Mummy was [__]
blowing up whole [__] cities with
sad storms and
as well yeah just crazy [__] man
I liked it but they'll never make
another one because it flopped
they were going to make a whole series a
whole universe based on well they start
they still kind of did that but they
just went a different direction because
they made Invisible Man like with
Elizabeth Moss but they just like went
like a more Indie movie direction or
like more Art House coming which I am
more in favor of that because like I
said you know the mummy
I don't think
that they needed to make another big
budget because they already did those
like with the Brendan Fraser series you
know those adventure movies I think that
was good but you know those were fun but
I don't think we needed more of that I
think if you were gonna remake The Mummy
make it more like the original like the
Boris Karloff one like more of like a
mystery or some of those characters in
that were really good Russell Crowe as
[__] Dr Jekyll man that was a [__]
badass seed and we started slipping into
Mr Hyde I was slipping right along with
him I was like yeah yeah that's right
yeah that's how I'm doing that's how I
go and like wait a minute hold on where
am I going now oh [__]
Mr Hyde yeah [__] I liked it man I
could have watched a whole movie of
Russell Crowe see I kind of wish this
whole movie had been Russell Crowe's had
been Russell Crowe as Mr Hyde although
you could argue that that one movie that
we saw with Russell Crowe doing like
that [__] road rage crazy [__]
remember that that's pretty good
um I I you could argue that that was a
whole Miss right that was pretty good I
mean I actually did like that he's
coming out with an exorcist movie I
think it's this month well like based on
like the exercise I think it's just like
and Exorcist it's called The vatican's
Exorcist I think or the pope oh so
that's probably oh I know what that's
about then it's about the original case
I think so it's kind of like okay uh all
right all right you got my attention
yeah and and uh he's doing a promotional
Tour on YouTube the ads are coming up
and he's talking about it looked good
man real good
Russell Crowe plays The Exorcist yeah we
might have to see that actually yeah
granthers also says you guys are the Tom
Cruise of podcasts always give it your
best always prepared and never suffer
the fools yeah but it's like the mummy
it's always a flop man
we need like a hundred thousand I'm
always prepared I'm not sure I try to be
prepared but sometimes it's like
sometimes I'm I start the show and I'm
just kind of like oh [__] do I know what
I'm talking about probably not yeah
grafter said uh Bridget Fonda had a car
wreck several years ago and then gained
150 pounds yeah see that's like that's
pretty shitty
that's pretty shitty
um yeah four-star down said I liked Edge
of Tomorrow too yeah I I also really
liked that which one was that oh yeah
yeah they were replaying it right right
yeah it was a good one too yeah I like
Oblivion I I liked it yeah and that was
the same director as Top Gun Mavericks
okay so
um you know that and I think that that's
where Jessica the guy that directed top
gun Maverick I think that was where he
met Tom Cruise was when they did
Oblivion
um Grant thur Hammer also says Rock of
Ages was stupid and he added to the
stupidity
what movie was that I don't remember
that one I don't remember that one
either
like was that another Tom Cruise movie
because I don't remember that one
yeah the Pope's Exorcist that's the
Pope's Exorcist that's what it's called
yeah
that's yeah that's probably that that
would probably be good I feel like the
trailers look good okay I'm gonna have
to get Washington Russell Crowe doesn't
interview about this movie in the
trailer he's referring to it you know
his professional opinion on on this
movie I guess yeah it's all meta
that's a little bit it looked good it
looked it looked uh we'll see you know
all right basically it's a reboot of The
Exorcist
based on the case that is based on well
see now that's it's a little boy it's a
little boy it's not a girl because I
feel like there have been one there have
been like 40 bajillion like exorcism
movies and you know I'm kind of it's
kind of like zombie movies at this point
where it's like I have fatigue about
that sub genre
but I kind of feel like they haven't no
one's made a movie based on the actual
case I mean have they well they just
they're leading me to believe that
that's what it is based upon trailer it
may not be based upon the actual case or
just Loosely Roland
um it looks like it's something else
Robbie Mannheim it almost looks like
something out of the conjure universe
okay do it visually what it look like
but it looked high-end
all right look good I mean you know we
could probably see that just it'll it'll
be on streaming yeah we never go to the
theater anymore so far I know it's too
far we live out the middle of [__]
nowhere now so it's just kind of like
they'll never build a theater around
here probably not there's not enough
people not the market well and yeah I
mean I do like seeing stuff in the
theater and like I said I kind of wish I
had seen this in the theater
um you know it's don't get me wrong it's
still like pretty amazing like on our
you know big screen TV but
and with the sound bar but I kind of
feel like seeing this like an IMAX or
something like that that would have been
[__] mindful although probably I told
him while we were watching it like
during all the flight sequences and
stuff I said you know if we'd seen this
in the theater I probably would have
thrown up in my lap because of all the
[__] ugh one of these days I'll go
down to Sam's enough when we have the
money and I'll get it I'll get a [__]
huge one
take up the whole wall yeah like almost
the whole wall
the whole the bedroom will be a movie
theater okay imagine the porn
I don't need to see porn that big okay
all right
dick the size of a Volkswagen but I
don't even see everybody's pores that's
pretty gross like see all their ingrown
hairs and all that
HD and she knows hairs it's like look
they've got a booger yeah you know so
you want to go ahead and make it a wrap
yeah well hold on he says Rock of Ages
that's a movie I asked about he said Tom
Cruise played Stacy Jacks a ripoff of
Axel Rose in this stinky turd of a movie
oh I've I've I okay now I have to see it
yeah
what year did that come out
two thousand man did they like bury it
because it was like I don't even
remember hearing about that one was it a
comedy that's what I wanted to know it
sounds like a comment I mean Tom Cruise
can do comedy right like sometimes but
he doesn't usually I kind of feel like
action movies are his the worst one I
remember is one where he's playing the
bartender cocktail cocktail that [__]
was stupid I think I saw that in the
theater yeah I think that was targeted
towards women
well I'm a woman and I didn't like it
you didn't like it either no I didn't
like it I barely remember it I erased it
from my mind like I said all I can
remember was Tom Cruise like smirking
and Swinging yeah and stuff and I was
just that's that's the only impression I
was left might have been Tom Cruise's
response to Coyote Ugly or something
I thought Coyote Ugly came out like
after that though because cocktail was
that's old I mean that came out of what
like 80 87 88 something like that late
80s yeah I think it was 87. yeah but
yeah I remember not really liking it all
that much because like I think it was
just kind of ugly was like early 90s
yeah I kind of feel like that was that
was like a 90s yeah it was like 92 yeah
so okay if anything Coyote Ugly might
have been ripping off yeah cocktail yeah
maybe which is crazy I don't really know
I didn't see I don't think I saw a
coyote ugly he was great in Rain Man
yeah Tom Cruise was great like I said
and we've said this before he can act
I'm not saying that he can do [__] but
it's just most of the time he just
chooses to be in yeah he's like I'm just
gonna be like smug [__] TM
that's kind of like his entire character
you know imagine if Tom Cruise got the
role of Batman
Batman I'm imagining five foot five
Batman
I mean don't you know okay here we go
crafter says thank you Tourette Rock of
Ages just don't hate me afterwards yeah
you could probably see that for free I
mean I can have like a really good time
with that I feel like I mean if it's as
bad as you say then I'm kind of like
looking forward to it because I think
that'd be good what okay all right now
it's like I said now I'm really curious
now I want to see it because I feel like
everybody like and now nowadays like
every time he's in a movie everyone's
like you know creaming themselves over
like how awesome it is so you know he's
really having kind of like a Renaissance
even though he's in his [__] 60s now
right which you know yeah I think he's
66. what's funny about him is that he
doesn't look like an old guy he looks
like a young guy that's old that's a
weird thing about it yeah that's what we
were saying we're watching he doesn't
look like an old guy he looks like a
young guy who happens to be old it's
like a weird kind of because in this
yeah his hair is too dark and a guy his
age doesn't have hair that thick it's
just it
he's
he's got the point where he's gonna have
to start looking playing an older guy or
to look like an older guy it's starting
to look kind of ridiculous if you ask me
it's just he looked I thought in this
his face he looks good but I thought his
face looked a little bloated yeah like
he had had like some surgery and it
hadn't really taken something exactly
something
he looks good from certain angles and
other angles he doesn't quite look as
yeah I was thinking to myself that maybe
they should have like not done any
close-ups is what I was thinking because
he looks good from like kind of middle
distance I think it's the hair
the hair might not be helping that's the
hair of a young man yeah he needs to
have that hair of a 60 year old if he's
gonna have hair or just shave himself
[__] bald yeah it looks a lot age
appropriate to have a [__] full set
of dark hair you know this shit's fake
at 60. at 60 your hair is going to be I
mean it's not quite late for Steven
Seagal level but yeah where he just like
right paints it on with shellac or
whatever it is that he does no in their
defense it's like well it's the movies
it's fantasy you know okay but I'm just
going nuts hair plugs man
airplanes are [__] and somebody asked
like somebody
um I was reading a review of it and they
were wondering about the age difference
between him and Jennifer Connelly no but
it's not it's not that much like I said
she's
51 yeah I think and he's 66 so that's
not terrible she looks a lot younger
than him I will give that but she's
actually not I mean she's significantly
younger than him but not weirdly some
women can hold it together for a long
long time look at Cassandra Peterson
she's 70 something and she's fine yeah
she looks fine Tom and still hit that oh
I'd hit it everybody everybody else it
hit it too
you'd hit that [__] I probably would
yeah yeah she she's cute
what's her name [__] Barbara uh
Barbara Barbara Crampton she's 60
something man she looks fancy she's hot
yeah
not all women look [__] up when they
get old just like guys you know not all
of them look [__] up some look all
right but it's going to take work
you know the metabolism just doesn't
want to do that you're going to need
supplementation and training and
surgeries little nips and Tucks here and
little adjustments every now and then
just keep up with things and you can
look good for a long long time
but you know if you look at
Cassandra Peterson also knows Elvira
that girl's not natural you know that's
not natural that's implants and
facial surgeries and hormones and you
know staying fit and but still it pays
off you know she's still got a career
she can dress up like [__] Elvira and
look just like the Elvira pretty much of
the 70s or the 80s when she was on
television it'd be just as sexy
yeah because we just saw her on the
because they did a thing on shutter like
just a few months ago and she was on
there
couldn't do that Vampira she's copying
melanoma vampire from
she couldn't do that at 60. she was a
hag at 60.
you know
well in their defense they didn't really
have a lot of the same knowledge back
then and a lot of the access to [__]
that we have here I don't like mail
ahead than money I think she died
selling handmade jewelry on welfare up
in her yeah which is sad because yeah
she's like such an icon yeah nowadays
that it's they drank a lot and they
smoked a lot and with that too and yeah
I'm sure that didn't help right and the
diet wasn't great yeah American Military
100 said the Pope's Exorcist is based on
the vatican's chief Exorcist who claimed
to have performed thousands of exorcisms
and kept detailed records okay so it's
not actually about the okay that
specific case all right that case wasn't
one of them evidently granther says my
wife is 13 years younger than me no
complaints yeah yeah see that's like not
weird no 15 or some guys in their 50s
married the second wife the second
wife's 20 years younger
that happens too
now you know they may only be together
for 10 15 years it depends on the
situation just you know
I think Steve's wife's nearly 20 years
younger than them
our friend Steve you know yeah
well there you go she's [__] giving
him three kids it appears I think two or
three two or three kids in a period of
just like three or four years I know
when he visited they had just had it
yeah but I think that was the first one
and that's been a few years yeah so I
don't know if they've had any other ones
I think he's got three now well [__]
that escalated quickly
he's putting a dent in it man
having all kind of little things running
around
all right so um yeah we're gonna wrap
this up um you know if you have Amazon
Prime you can watch top gun Maverick
absolutely worth watching uh like I said
I'm not a big fan of the first movie but
I actually really uh like this one it
was pretty entertaining and all the
flight stuff was like amazing uh so you
can just watch it for that because
that's [__] incredible no matter if
you like the movie or not uh so yeah so
tomorrow is Monday and that means it's a
haunting Mondays I think we're gonna go
back to season two
and discuss the attic because no that's
season three season three episode two
that's why I got confused uh because I
think we watched it a while back and we
were gonna do a show about it and I
don't think we ever did so I think
that's one of the ones that
from the first four seasons that we
haven't covered yet so that's probably
the one that we're gonna do uh so you
know I'll let you know if anything
changes but yeah
all right so hopefully you guys can join
us for that tomorrow evening at 7 30
Eastern Standard Time and thanks for
dropping by today thanks for the money
to rent Rock of Ages because now I
really want to see that because I was
like super curious uh so yeah uh we will
see you guys again tomorrow night good
night